what they do is the baby right now I'm
gonna bleach report playing baby on baby
let's go
that's a Anthony Davis easy let's go
Chris Paul with bland with baby quit
playing with baby
Chris Paul that James are without the
beer I could tell by he got all right my
bad Jim you look different
you look different damn that ain't quite
Lynn it's a nice skin baby you can't
even [ __ ] me Brett Kauai you can't fault
me for that look like he used to be a
little pretty boy as a baby the lady
took my girlfriend and they cut that's
KD KD for sho that is a klay Thompson
[Music]
that's my boy Ron quit playing there's
no boy Brian that's got to be got to be
him right there you know who that is
i hain't got to change that is that's
the one who got ya I really don't I
really don't fool with you and that's
the biggest bottle of them all
it was like a turkey baby right dinner
you know big big number one album in the
world you did once and dedicated to my
pops you know splitting image of me
featuring some of the best artists in
the world including stunts of own Vegas
a bit not a bit of entertainment yeah
this bleacher report and this baby on
babies